for instance you know your transition
into angel
now was that something that they
approached you early on did joss or
anybody say hey we have these plans for
you to be on angel were you were you
surprised that they're they want you to
be on angel
uh they
he came to me
uh it was certainly before we finished
filming buffy it was before the the the
summer
uh it was a few months before so yeah i
had some lead time
uh
and apparently they had gotten canceled
and joss was trying to going back and
forth with network what was canceled
angel angel was cancelled and season
going into season five so after season
four they canceled it and joss was like
well what if we do this can i can i have
another season what if i do that and
then he found when he said what if i can
get spike they were like oh well if you
can get spike you can you can go for
another scene and so he called me did
you know that he needed you or did you
not realize that i didn't know that
dynamic that would have been a thing
called leverage
uh
well i found it out and yes
and it helped
it did but um
it took a long time and it it taught me
to not be angry
with producers when they tried to screw
me
that's so hard because you take it
personally yeah and and uh i i thought
back to the days when i was paying
actors
uh when i had a theater company we only
had 60 seats so it's the same problems
but in a smaller right i paid people 18
of performance and but that's what you
had yeah but that's
what they had
and do you think that's see that's what
they tell you they had well here we go
here we go so
um
i
i held out for the amount of money that
i was making on buffy i i because josh
said we don't have a lot of money on
angels not like buffy we it's we have
some money it's not a cheap show
obviously but it's not the same as buffy
uh
and i i told him i said look when you
told me that i said i'm not going to
hold out for more than i was making on
buffy but you're offering me less and i
didn't really
think that was gonna happen and i'm not
really gonna gonna go
for that right
and
charisma uh got a phone call saying that
we we can't have you in for the season
five
which was very painful for her and i
have to ask myself did i
in me
holding to that amount of money mean
that they had to make a decision and and
shrink the cast
so they didn't bring her back for season
five yeah and
partially probably to pay me
so you feel bad even though it's not
your fault you were just getting what
you were thought you were worth it's
called business yeah exactly i mean
obviously it's it makes you think oh
[ __ ] i hope that
she has a kid
did you ever talk to her about that yeah
you did yeah and what did you say to her
i didn't you know i mean she knows she's
part of the biz she doesn't you know
hold any grudges or anything but uh
but i have a feeling that that
obviously you know that's if i was
signing the checks that would be my
thinking we can only afford these many
actors and if i could have gotten james
for half price i would go to charisma
and see if she could right for half
price or whatever and maybe we could
keep everybody around but nope